les syndicats vincent et richard
travaille dans une grande usine de
construction automobile
leur patron vient de leur annoncer qu'il
y allait avoir un plan de licenciement
inquiets ils vont voir françois le
représentant syndical de leur usine
françois leur explique que tout n'est
pas perdu après tout il y à d'autres
usines dans le groupe et la marque
plutôt que de licencier pour et
reclasser tout le monde
françois explique aux deux ouvriers
qu'une négociation entre les syndicats
et le patronat commencent les syndicats
ouvriers ont été créée en 1884 pour
représenter les salariés face aux
patrons depuis les syndicats ont obtenu
plus de pouvoir il siège dans des
comités d'entreprise des entreprises de
plus de 50 salariés
ces comités n'ont pas de pouvoir de
gestion mais ils participent à
l'organisation de la vie collective
ils sont informés des performances et
les projets de l'entreprise
les plus grands syndicats français sont
la cgt la cfdt fo la cftc et la cgc
tous les salariés de france peuvent se
syndiquer ils peuvent aussi dans
certains cas préférez des syndicats plus
spécialisés
le snes pour les enseignants alliance
pour la police la fnsea pour les
agriculteurs les syndicats il y en a
pour tout le monde y compris pour les
patrons comme le medef où la cgpme dans
les entreprises ou les administrations
les syndicats défendent les salariés
participent aux négociations salariales
au niveau national depuis 1946 les cinq
principaux syndicats cogère avec les
organisations patronales des grands
organismes sociaux on appelle ça la
gestion paritaire
c'est comme ça par exemple qu'elle
gérait l'unedic l'organisme qui s'occupe
de la distribution de l'assurance
chômage ou la sécurité sociale pour le
remboursement des dépenses de santé
souvent quand le gouvernement veut
réformer la législation du travail ou
des retraites et l'organisent de grandes
négociations entre les syndicats de
patrons et de salariés
tout le monde est prié par le
gouvernement de se mettre d'accord sur
une réforme mais en france ce que l'on
appelle les partenaires sociaux trouvent
très rarement des accords et c'est
finalement le plus souvent le goût
ornements qui propose des réformes quand
on imagina syndicalistes allemands on
voit un négociateur en costume quand on
pense à un syndicaliste français
on a plutôt l'image d'un ouvrier sur un
piquet de grève avec un mégaphone
en france les syndicats très
revendicatif tente d'obtenir des
avancées pour les salariés en organisant
des grèves ou des manifestations la
manif du 1er mai et le rassemblement
traditionnel pour les syndicats cette
année vincent et richard qui n'avaient
jamais manifesté ils sont allés avec les
camarades de leur usine ils ont retrouvé
françois le syndicaliste et ils lui ont
annoncé la bonne nouvelle il se
syndiquent et c'est une bonne chose
parce que malgré l'importance des
syndicats dans la vie démocratique et
sociale il n'y a que 8 % des salariés
qui sont inscrits à un syndicat en
france
quand